most guys are young and they start they
they start off really sweet and what
they're doing is they're looking for a
young wife that wants to get married or
try to treat her well and they find out
that when they treat girls well they
don't get laid but we can say the same
thing for women I think the reason why
women and listen the thing is if women
no wrong wrong wrong no no because
you're going to say something with women
like do the same thing that's what you
said and that's wrong because if women
did the same thing we would have more to
offer but the average modern woman
doesn't have much to offer two men in
terms of what men value if women did so
much they would stay pure for their
husbands we don't we would know how to
cook we don't I think the average girl
buried young we don't I think they don't
they don't have a concept of like
healthy boundaries that a guy naturally
knows like not talking or keeping
communication with men you've slept with
in the past that's like a big No-No for
guys like because we we know that that
dude is just a predator just sitting
around waiting for his chance to get
another taste